це Тетяна їй 19 років Вона студентка
одного з Київських вишів Катерині 31
Вона працює в банку а з 24 лютого
займалася волонтерством на перший погляд
цього непомітно але обидві дівчини
борються зі шрамами які залишила війна
[музика]
ось ми з вами приходимо до будинку там
була моя родина під час вибуху коли з
нами це все сталося
і ми бачимо що з нього залишилось пані
руїни всі дивуються що ми сталися живи
мені посідання яке вийде десь
прогулятися вони може друг підійти як це
сталося жива і посиди не можу знайти
твір я так кажу Я тоже не знаю і все
після повномасштабного вторгнення РФ
Тетяна Приїхала до батьків у село
небелиця на Київщині коли росіяни
підійшли в притул до села сім'я
перебралася у будинок до родичів 28
лютого російський снаряд упав поруч із
їхньою оселею я почула вибух десь далеко
був і хочу сказати що Ходім тебе знову
бахки я нічого не встигла сказати
в мене вже Просто йшла з кров з лиця і
все І тільки чула на задньому фоні крики
своєї мами Діти веде виходьте десятки
дрібних осколків посікли обличчя Тетяни
Ось так дівчина виглядала після того як
лікарі зашили рани молодий лікар Андрій
Васильєв був одним з перших хто працював
з пораненнями Тетяни він асистент
пластичного хірурга але в кінці лютого
виїхав з Києва і надавав допомогу
пораненим у звичайній лікарні в обличчі
були
уламки скла ліва частина була посічена і
вона дуже боялась що вона втратила око
але дякувати Богу цього не сталося я її
завжди заспокоював що ми все зробимо
відновимо обличчя буде все класно
але вона в це не вірила насправді лікар
і сам спершу сумнівався що обличчя
Тетяни буде таким як і раніше Ось так
дівчина виглядала вже через два місяці у
квітні На той момент я уже можна сказати
став більш впевненіший що результат буде
більш-менш нормальним бо воно нормально
стягнулося дівчина стала учасницею
програми ноускар без шрамів це
ініціатива українських пластичних
хірургів які безкоштовно загоюють рубці
постраждали двійни до неї долучилися 40
лікарів з різних українських міст Сергій
Королюк один з них Тетяна стала його
першою пацієнткою зі слідами від війни у
її випадку минулося без операцій Ми
спочатку робили
медикаментозні якісь корекції правильні
перев'язки використання всяких
допоміжних засобів для заживлення ран і
рубців і вже на останньому етапі вже
почали проводити там такі хірургічні
лазерні коригування цих хлопців
віза мету зробити обличчя до Нового року
сумлінно виконувала поради лікарів
робила масажі обличчя нині Вона майже
нічим не відрізняється від дівчини на
фото в кімнаті хіба стала дещо
дорослішою потрібно йти вперед не
дивлячись ні на що і пам'ятати ти в себе
одна єдина щоб не сталося Ти завжди була
гарна будеш гарно Не дивлячись ні Які в
тебе можуть бути травми тому потім люди
яким ти справді будеш потрібно вони
будуть поруч з тобою Не дивлячись на те
що тобто люблять не за лице а скажемо за
перш за все сама яка ти людина
Катерина 24 лютого виїхала з Києва до
рідного Коростеня там приєдналася до
місцевих волонтерів вони збирались
спорядження для військових возили їжу на
блокпости під час однієї з таких поїздок
блокпоста атакував ворожий безпілотник Я
якраз цей момент говорила по телефону і
буквально секунда я закриваю очі Я
відкриваю я лежу на асфальті і дикий
писк в ушах
я бачу лежу і стоїть так військовий він
дивиться на мене Він певно думав що я
мертва поки я не почала рухатись в той
момент вбила 5 людей одразу на тому
місці мене просто врятувала диво і Бог
можна сказати ангел-охоронець я відповім
що ми цього пояснити Не можу дівчина
говорить що спершу навіть не відчувала
болю насправді ж її тіло просили уламки
бетону виходить отак на вильот пройшов
осколок просто нас з однієї сторони то
есть вхідний вид отвір і вихідний і оце
місце зашивала це воно Ну найважче
заживало
ну це на груді було тут на руці теж опік
лишився Шрам Ну так до 8 десь таких от
по тілу слідів в мене лишилося
Через такі сліди на тілі Катерина
звернулася до лікарів які працюють за
ініціативою ноускар і безкоштовно
отримала допомогу у червні їй провели
операцію з корекції шрамів за рік шрами
затягуються і біліють лазерна корекція
майже повністю їх прибере цю процедуру
дівчина ще планує зробити Ти звикла до
себе одної до того да Ти звикла себе
бачити в дзеркалі одною да А коли ти
бачиш ці сліди ну це психологічно
повертає тебе іноді в той момент і Ну ти
розумієш що ти вже нічого змінити не
можеш Але є можливість прибрати ці шрами
і психологічно тобі стає від цього легше
лікар Сергій Королюк готується оперувати
ще одного постраждалого через бойові дії
волонтери з бородянки якого поранило
після прильоту міни прибрати цей Шрам і
відновити по можливості м'язи зробити
таку пластику м'язів щоб вони виконували
опорну функцію захисну блоку бо бачите
нерівно а тут така як гуляти пластичний
хірург уже консультує Кілька десятків
людей травмованих війною у всіх є дещо
спільне коли вони
отримали ці травми і десь незадоволені
своїм зовнішнім виглядом в них
проявляється така як замкнутість і часом
навіть спілкування з ними Вони тримають
якусь таку дистанцію але вже потім коли
вони бачать якісь результати то це
трошки проходить і розгальмовується
лікарі не втрачають Надії що шрами війни
можна загоїти принаймні зовнішні
[музика]